joining us for more on this California
Congressman Tom McClintock a republican
on the Judiciary Committee it's good to
have you sir what do you want to
accomplish today
well first and foremost we want to hear
from the people who are most immediately
affected by this border crisis and sound
a warning to the rest of the country
that that every community in America has
now become a border community and these
problems are going to be facing every
community in America I mean the numbers
are staggering just since this
Administration took office they
deliberately admitted 1.9 million
illegal immigrants 800 000 of whom were
not even given notices to appear and
while the border patrol has been
overwhelmed with that another 1.2
million uh known godaways have entered
the country as well so that's 3.1
million that is a population larger than
the entire state of Arkansas a state
that has seven congressional seats just
in the last 25 months the vast
proportion of these people are homeless
impoverished desperate uh and we have to
ask ourselves the impact on the schools
on the hospitals uh on the uh on on
working Americans job prospects of
what's going on with with
introducing this mass of fentanyl into
our neighborhoods uh how we're how does
this affect communities introducing
violent cartels into them and making it
all but impossible to deport criminal
illegal aliens That's Not Just Happening
Here it's going to be happening across
the country if it isn't already in your
community it will be very soon sir Singh
is believing I know you know that you
know unless you go down and see for
yourself it doesn't take on the
understanding of the impact that you
have but you're from California and your
wall is finished it's 160 miles long in
the Yuma sector alone which extends
about 110 to 118 miles there are gaps
all over the place and that's part of
the reason why Yuma's got so many
problems
why would your Democratic colleagues not
want to see that
I believe it's deliberate policy I think
it's calculated for two years we
couldn't get the Democrats to hold a
single hearing on this crisis not one uh
in the first six weeks of this session
Republicans have held two we've come
down to the border to ask the people who
are at Ground Zero to tell us about
their experiences and not a single
Democrat on the committee shown up to
listen I think that speaks for itself
Jerry Nadler Congressman of course from
New York he's the ranking member on
Judiciary he gave this statement saying
that instead of focusing on real
solutions to a complicated problem
Judiciary Republicans will once again
not hear from any federal government
Witnesses at their hearing further
cementing this hearing as a Brazen Act
of political grandstanding why is that I
don't understand that you could be in
Washington and have a hearing they
didn't have a hearing you could have
Washington Witnesses it doesn't matter
where you are there are people being
affected by this right there where you
are which is I assume why you wanted to
take the hearing on the road in the
first place
right we've we've heard from
Administration officials for the last
two years assuring us that there is no
crisis the border is secure I'm sure
we'll be hearing more and more from them
but those words sound very Hollow when
you come down here and actually view the
situation sir thank you for your time
and we'll be looking at your headlines
from your hearing today Tom McClintock
thank you the Republican from California
and Yuma down there I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis